we will be drafting the duos in the
national football league that we would
most like to see
again and it can be any of them
all time
all the way back to red grange and jim
thorpe if you want chris if you've heard
of either of them and i hope that you i
have you've you've got the trivia
question you ask it to me if i get it
right i get the first pick go
okay here we go tom brady and rob
gronkowski have combined for the fifth
most touchdowns of any duo in the
history of the nfl
one more td between the two will tie
them with what other former afc east duo
for fourth all time
this is ridiculous how am i supposed to
know who's fourth all time on the
on the receiving list of quarterbacks
let's calm down here
no no no be quiet you need it you're a
baby go ahead you sure
yeah i'll just i'll just throw a dart
i'll say i'll say jim kelly and andre
reid
sims is frozen
are you back there are you back sims or
are you gone i'm back i'm here i'm here
do you hear me
uh yeah i was waiting to find out
whether or not i got it right jim kelly
and andre reed
oh that would have been one of the two
right answer or two of the guesses i
would have got but you got it wrong
sorry suck it trebek you're wrong
what about dan marino and mark duper yes
yes you're right way to go yes that's
right you're right it's dan marino and
mark clayton not clayton not duper yep
all right
go ahead the first pick not that it
matters in this draft because we can go
in about a thousand different directions
we really can i mean it's if there's too
many there's too many things that to
pick here but
i i mean okay if i'm gonna pick like the
most special combination i ever remember
right
you know i've got to start with montana
and rice i mean
i know steve young and rice had more
touchdowns together than montana and
rice but
the two super bowls that montana and
rice played in won the blowout in denver
where rice and montana were phenomenal
montana threw five touchdown passes then
of course you know super bowl 23 with
the bengals and you know our chris
collinsworth and boomer assistant versus
that 49ers football team i mean they
just were special moments and that just
was a special combination throughout the
and there he goes again all right
technical difficulties for christopher
david sims he has joe montana and jerry
rice i'll go ahead and make my pick and
if he's not back it's kind of like the
vikings in 2002 the clock runs out or
was it 2003 it may have been both years
the clock runs out i'll make my next
pick it's not my fault you're getting a
glimpse of what it's going to be like
thursday night when there are technical
difficulties during the real draft all
right so the most uh let's see
there are a lot of different ways i can
go he did take the one that kind of
stood out for me joe montana and jerry
rice i'll tell you what i'm gonna go
with one that didn't last a long time
but when it burned it burned as brightly
as any combination we've ever seen in
league history and that's tom brady and
randy moss 2007 the greatest season
we've ever seen from a receiver better
than anything rice ever did and look
with tom brady he's done it with so many
different receivers we really don't
think of one and if we think of one i
guess we think of gronk but for that
brief moment in time before gronkowski
was even on the team that year that they
went 18-0 and ultimately 18-1 losing to
the giants in super bowl 42 tom brady
and randy moss were as special as any
quarterback and receiver have ever
been
all right if sims isn't back i guess
i'll go ahead and take his pick is sims
back we have sims oh damn it i thought i
was gonna get to steal your picks
yep sorry i i mean i don't know what the
hell happened my my ipad i don't know
what happened either what's his giant
head on my screen yeah sorry because i'm
holding my phone right now because for
some reason when you know the control
room called back my ipad didn't connect
i don't know what the hell is going on
but
okay i'm gonna go
with randy moss and chris carter as my
second pick okay
i'm gonna go with that just as a as a
high school kid about to go into college
man moss and carter on the same time
with the minnesota vikings football team
and then throwing the ball deep down the
field i mean that was just exciting i
mean to me that was like that's the best
receiver combo i think of my lifetime
for sure those are arguably two of the
five or six greatest receivers ever in
the history of the sport and they played
together you know with chris carter
being sort of the edge of his prime but
randy moss certainly in his prime so
that's a special one to me that um you
know i'll always remember see and i
can't think of those guys as a duo
because
jake reed was part of that group as well
and they had the hats that said three
and stop it i'm telling you
jake jake reed was was the guy
who kind of helped carry the vikings
through those dark days after the
herschel walker trade when they didn't
have any draft picks i'm telling you it
was carter moss and reed for a few years
there and they burned very brightly so
uh all right but i hear you and moss now
has made it back-to-back picks we got
tom brady and randy moss we got randy
moss and chris carter how about how
about a little um
you know and even though they didn't
generate huge numbers they're both in
the hall of fame and they had some of
the most famous catches in super bowl
history one in super bowl 10 the other
in super bowl
14.
lynn stallworth or wait a minute lynn
swann and john stallworth or lynn
stallworth and john swan either way the
two steelers receivers from the 70s
again not the kind of numbers we would
have seen from them if they were playing
today chris but spectacular postseason
performers spectacular super bowl
performers you really are max headroom
today gimme lynn swann and john
stallworth
oh well yeah they're on my list as well
i mean that that's a special combo right
there i mean when you're talking about
four super bowls and you know in an era
where
defense and running the football
certainly was a little bit more popular
man terry bradshaw and that group there
they could they could push the ball down
the field
and they wanted to throw bombs they
weren't into throwing like four yard out
rounds or anything like that so i'm with
you they were certainly on my list all
right
damn and i didn't know you picked brady
and moss already i wouldn't have picked
that if i if i knew you had already done
that i would have changed it up a little
bit but i'm gonna go with reggie white
and clyde simmons you know because i'm
going a little personal with some of
these guys as you can tell because they
were just such a huge part of my life
and especially reggie white and clyde
and your dad's life
what exactly i mean i used to go to
eagles giants games in fear for my dad's
life legend like literally i would be
sitting there and going man i mean i
hope the giants win but more importantly
i hope my dad doesn't like die out of
the field today and get crushed to death
because there was he had a few injuries
playing that that football team but you
know hey can you imagine as a
nine-year-old kid you know going to a
game and watching your dad have to deal
with jerome brown todd simmons reggie
white buddy ryan and that defense uh
those were some of my most nervous
movements as a viewer as a as a child
growing up watching my father play
football
all right i like that one and actually
you know we have been aspirational with
these these uh desires to see
duos of the past together again
there's also a way to want to see a
couple of guys come together again for
reasons that would constitute chaos
i want to see t.o and donovan mcnabb
together again i want them to be on the
same team i want them to be on the same
field i want them to be in the same
locker room the same bus the same plane
especially given the history they had in
philadelphia that would be worth the
price of admission and that would be the
kind of chaos that makes the nfl go
around chris
oh well yeah i mean oh shocker mike
wants to see chaos i would have never
guessed you want to pick something like
that but anybody watching this show is
seeing chaos right now with your with
your camera my god hold it still i'm
getting nauseous
well my shoulder is getting tired right
now i'm not i'm making the call i'm
getting the shoulder workout right here
so shut up okay
but all the great
kind of like us maybe that's why i went
in that path
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports